hey welcome back to the break room
everybody it's our daily nerdy news show
it keeps you up to date on what you need
to know and you know what today I'm
sorry to give a bad diagnosis but we're
all infected oh no with a Mania oh it's
Quantum
coming up today we're gonna be talking
Quantum media we're gonna be talking
about this big Marvel news that uh the
Marvels that Marvel just kind of snuck
out low-key thinking nobody would notice
they had an Easter egg on one of their
posts yes a big Easter egg uh and and
some other stuff uh with me to do that
today we've got Brandon Barracks here
that's right and all seven of my holes
are here as well whoa oh hey
um don't don't tease us with a good time
um Jessica Clemens is here hi who's my
name oh I'm in the right time
and then uh T Michael Beck told him
quantumania is not the only disease I've
been diagnosed with recently oh herpes
herpes simplex b b for Bechtel yes I
actually they said that the uh the only
herpes they've ever found that in are
herpes and manatees I have Manatee
herpes oh congratulations because of all
those body parts you got from animals
National Geographic said
a manatee's nipples are in its armpit no
it's not that's true wow I've never felt
closer to a manatee moving on they're
like Navi
um uh oh both Tommy and I are are
wearing some some new Merchants
available at nerdriot.shop uh Tommy's
wearing one of our Quantum Mania designs
a Quantum Thief sure I really like that
one and then I'm repping our new channel
the astronaut yeah this is astronaut
named after Eric Voss uh we just
launched that channel today there's some
really great content up there a video
about Loki a video about one division uh
Eric did a almost 90 minute live
breakdown of quantumania we got him
hooked up to IVs right now
pretty harder before but I brought him
back to life Eric always works really
hard but the the volume and intensity of
work he's been putting in to get this
new channel off the ground has been a
wild so hey if you're not already go
over there subscribe watch those videos
uh they're they're long in depth awesome
videos it'll take you a minute but
they're so worth your time did you say
they go deep
I'd say they dive deep wow
uh hey let's get into some headlines
John hold it together Offspring producer
John dying slowly in the background now
off camera what's uh what's his
diagnosis do you think diagnosis hunk
syndrome oh baby baby baby baby baby
baby
the sad part is hung syndrome is fatal I
was in trouble
uh you died within seven to ten hours of
sexiness yeah uh so the the the news we
kind of mentioned there uh we got a new
poster out for the Marvels which was
awesome it's a really cool stylized
poster with Kamala Khan there it is whoa
uh right Monica Rambo and uh Brie
Larson's Captain Marvel and then Kamala
Khan really cool uh Graphics the color
scheme everything uh but there's a key
piece of information new information on
that poster a release date of November
10th hey so it's a special day yeah it's
Tommy's birthday that's my birthday oh
Tommy happy birthday will be having a
Marvel themed birthday party for me I'm
turning 24 and I've never felt more
stressed to succeed You Look Marvelous
wow
these bags might be 24. but the marbles
had been previously slated for July 28th
of this year so it's getting moved back
a few months now the November 10th was
not exactly but in November blade had
originally been yeah it was gonna be
like the week after like November 17th
November 24th but yeah they kind of slid
it into that and Guardians is May
Guardians is still May that's not moving
you know what that makes me think a lot
of TV coming in the summer well so yeah
we're going to talk about that and you
know there's been a lot of news lately
uh there's a Hollywood Reporter about
Marvel specifically uh article about
Marvel and kind of like Kevin feige we
talked about this on the show yesterday
they might be kind of maybe doing
slightly fewer projects and maybe
spacing them out more specifically
Disney plus projects I don't think
they're gonna go from like three or four
movies a year to two or anything like
that they need those movies they're huge
IP they make a lot of money but the
Disney plus series it seems like they
might be backing away from those a
little bit last year we got three movies
three series and two special
presentations this year we're getting
three movies
question mark series double question
mark special presentations none of those
have been announced and and the rumor is
the only series we're guaranteed to get
this year Marvel series our secret
Invasion that could come out any day now
the rumor is maybe May and then
um Loki season two sometime in the
summer so that might be in between
Guardians and the Marvels we get low-key
it would be crazy it would be absolutely
an insane marketing stunt but not and I
realize when I sound like I'm saying
something serious you think it's going
to be just a dirty joke this is a real
thing that I have and if I were working
at Disney don't make that face at me I
would make it again
thank you all right hey wouldn't the
ultimate way to release secret Invasion
would be to put out a fake movie yes
that is not a like like like Disney
presents the All-Stars and it's like uh
this skateboarding gang of Misfits and
then three minutes into the movie it's
just the pilot of secret Invasion and
then the show starts wow I would like
that I mean to to secretly drop secret
Invasion would be very on brand right
right yeah wouldn't that be fun like if
it was like the secret Invasion the show
is also secretly invading Our Lives am I
playing 4D chess right here yeah listen
I had a whole tub of popcorn this
morning for breakfast and it had extra
butter on it I'm seeing into the future
and the future is heart attack all right
galaxy brain Bechtel over here his
popcorn came in this uh yeah yes that's
right popcorn came in and you know some
people have been speculating and just
sorry the the end of that Switcheroo is
actually moved up the release of the
Haunted Mansion movie that is now gonna
be getting released yeah
um on that in that July window when the
Marvel's was going to be released
actually that movie looks like it's
gonna be really cool and I think that's
good because you think of like November
that's right around Halloween you don't
want a haunted house movie around then
you got to put it in July when people
are doing fireworks and water skiing
well we're having a little too much fun
on their summer vacation conspiracy
theory that this is so that that can be
on Disney plus by Halloween okay you
know what now you're playing 4D chess
with me welcome to the popcorn um but
and then I've heard a lot of speculation
right like that uh you know secret
Invasion might be setting up the marbles
uh right we know Carol Danvers and
um Nick Fury obviously have a big
history together she's kind of linked
with sword and Scrolls and shield and
all this kind of stuff and in the comics
and then the film version thus far do we
think there is some kind of setup
because maybe part of the delay too is
secret Invasion might be delayed a
little bit so thus they also have to
delay the Marvels yeah I mean it makes
sense because we know Nick Fury is going
to be in secret Invasion and it seems
like there's two parallel stories going
on in in Marvel right now right
whatever's going on with the government
and like Tech and between like armor
Wars and New World Order and secret
Invasion and all that stuff and then
whatever Kang is up to on the other side
and eventually those two stories will
cross at an important Venture but like
for the most part only some people know
what Kang is up to the words not out yet
and it you know who knows what ant-man's
gonna tell people that hangs up to I
don't know and we kind of need secret
Invasion to kind of not retcon but right
now the skrulls are sympathetic kind of
victims of Cree oppression
ostensibly secret invasion is going to
establish some squirrels as a threat
right like we don't have that right now
we just have Charming squirrels we love
voice by voice by Ben mendelsohn so yeah
the verse and
the realm for Marvel said that uh uh
Carol Danvers could go into the quantum
realm so if her if it's like connected
as if like oh someone that's a scroll is
pretending to be Carol Danvers uh and
they have the ability to go into the
quantum realm it makes sense that that's
why they had to push it so it's like
okay we need secret Invasion and we need
Carol Danvers to line up perfectly
because scrolls are going to pretend to
be here and go into the quantum realm
and do all these other things uh that's
all I wanted
yeah yeah great and and again I don't
we're hoping especially we who consume
and love so much Marvel content this is
not a sign that they're going to make
fewer movies or at least fewer movies
anytime soon because there's a special
issue with the blade movie needing to be
delayed we're definitely or fingers
crossed getting that next year start
shooting very soon 10 weeks right or
something like that yeah I think yeah I
think we're kind of Marvel likes to put
out about four movies a year that's like
you know you get a spring to Summer and
a fall and damn it take our money uh
we'll see what other impacts some of
these changes might have long term but
again uh we hope it's just so that they
can make some awesome movies and and
they all tie together now uh we should
forewarn everybody obviously this is
going to be a spoiler filled okay
quantumania discussion you've seen the
movie yes now that's okay if you haven't
seen the movie and you've watched up
until now and you've loved it let's be
honest every second uh just pause here
put this in your little uh watch later
folder on YouTube tube and come back and
watch us whenever you've gotten to the
movies that's what John's doing okay we
got some borders we'll put up a little
uh spoiler board and and also or just
watch because we're gonna tell a story
so beautiful it'll Eclipse any
theatrical experience you have by the
way E.T goes home at the end of the
movie whoa okay The Goonies defeat the
Fratelli family what Jack falls into the
water and freezes that's right DiCaprio
dies in almost every movie he's in
because that dude doesn't want to do a
sequel that's true never did a sequel
what
well I guess we can start yeah one yeah
they're we're working on the technical
uh ramifications but trust that we're
about to get into spoilers yeah so I
could do some non-spoilery thoughts well
let's let's get into initial thoughts
and feelings and like we don't have to
get into like reviews or tomato meters
or anything like that but like as you're
walking out of the theater what are your
big like kind of takeaways or the things
that left the biggest impression on you
well for me due to a variety of
circumstances my viewing of it was
delayed delayed delayed so I got to
accumulate a lot of other people's
opinions I left that theater
I loved that movie I really liked it I
mean I guess I guess love maybe love is
too strong I think we have gone away
from being able to evaluate comic book
movies for the silly things that they
are comic books are inherently kind of
silly some graphic novels aren't and
some storylines handle heavier themes
but like we're talking about people in
Tights that we are spoiler banners
I think uh
I I know this is not this is this is a
longer thought I this movie to me can be
evaluated as a fun very creative very
interesting World establishing like
almost kind of a a space movie set in a
Quantum realm I guess is how I felt
about it and I thought that we're going
to more they made some really
interesting choices specifically with
the characters who were born and lived
in the quantum realm and how they
interacted with everyone who came from
up there so I'd love to talk more about
that later but I'm gonna let other
people speak yeah my favorite thing
about it was the quantum realm and we
kind of talked about this on inside
Marvel where
um to disagree I think we didn't learn a
lot about the quantum realm before all
we knew is that you can get in there
with pin particles magic and the quantum
tunnel and this way we are now learning
about the hierarchy the power of the
system how everything works within the
quantum realm and that's a big big
information we never got because we can
keep bringing up the microverse but the
microverse is not the quantum realm
there's some things that kind of go over
but it's not the same we have the
quantum Row in the MCU so it's like
everything we're learning about the
inside workings of the quantum realm
what exists inside of it we're learning
in this movie uh overall I thought the
movie was okay
I I yeah I had a fun time felt like an
Ant-Man movie had a lot of humor uh I
have a lot of questions so many
questions were my answers I don't think
that that movie was the final conclusion
that people thought it was going to be
and I think that is part of the in my
opinion people that are struggling with
it it didn't it's it kind of continued
the theme of phase four which has been
established some new things ask a lot of
questions offer very little answers and
don't really connect to something coming
in the future we're gone are the days of
Thor's hammer being the post-credit team
because you know Thor is coming right
like now it's like oh there's a whatever
we'll get into it like this is this is
ostensibly something that could happen
further down the road or these are
people we'll see later but it's not a
like a literal bridge to the next
project and I think that's bumping when
you change the formula there's going to
be pushback there will be people that
are like this isn't what I expected this
isn't what I've been promised by this
studio with their Marvel movies but for
me it didn't bother me but I understand
why people would be bothered I feel the
reason it kind of bother people is
because it's the opening to phase five
so it's like I get that it's the
introduction and so I wanted to be the
introduction kind of how like wakanda
forever was like the good the farewell
package to the phase four it's like okay
I will give I was like Jeff leviness has
a lot to carry on his shoulders
introducing phase five and so I just
wanted to lay up for the next movie
right and sorry to interrupt uh we
should say like hey put your big
thoughts your big questions in the chat
we'll be trying to answer as many
especially at the at the end of this
episode we'll get through as many
questions uh thoughts uh fun bits as we
can uh sorry go ahead Brandon I was just
gonna say the movie two is in a weird
spot where it's like the next movie out
is Guardians of the Galaxy which is kind
of telling its own separate right story
and wrapping up its own little Trilogy
yeah so it is it is setting up a lot for
phase five I don't know how much it ties
into their next movie well and I don't
know how much Guardians is gonna tie
into phase five what kind of oh sorry no
that's all I'm gonna say is I think
that's what the high value
those will connect to the
eternals it will connect to the the
mystical part and then it will also
connect to grounded like uh government
Parts yeah because I think it's a it's
an interesting and ambitious decision to
start your face with the concluding
chapters of two trilogies right like
it's like this is what's launching this
new phase the last well I guess maybe
not the last Ant-Man movie but possibly
the last Ant-Man movie possibly the pro
definitely the last Guardians movie in
that iteration you know so with that
with that crew so it is kind of hard
because you're right you want them to
like this movie did not feel conclusive
in any way with the Ant-Man yeah yeah I
mean not none of the like big shocking
who's gonna live who's gonna die who's
gonna stay in terms of the the original
Ant-Man cast really ended up being
consequential in any way you know except
for Corey stall who bit it twice now
two-time loser I like my war heroes
capturing oh wow
well let's let's go ahead and and start
diving into some of the big questions I
think a lot of people had right coming
out of the the movie uh the first one
um as we as we launch into our next big
bad for this phase and and possibly
Beyond was this version of Kang a good
guy dude I I I I ride that he was I
think that the the good versions of
Kings I argue he who remains being a
good version of King possibly are the
kings that are King inflicted with their
with their mores because you get to that
post-credits scene we see the Council of
Kings not many of those Kang seemed very
conflicted they seemed like they were
ready to to uh cancel some people they
were ready to go on a a killing killing
spree no okay okay hang on hang on
let me think Hang Fish well you say you
say he romance is a good King is he a
good King well I mean I think in the
Spectrum it what is good what is evil
time is a prison okay that's people
don't understand how time works and I
think like one thing that good well
rounded villains have is they're
convinced they're good guys right like
that's what in their mind they're doing
the right thing right well they keep
trying to warn the humans or or whoever
that they come into encounter with and
maybe it's all a lie maybe it's the like
you know the charismatic con man but
they seem to be warning them hey I'm the
better version of what's to come you
kill me you open the floodgates For
Worse versions now we have two people
who have basically now said that so is
that Kang is that any Kang backed into a
Corner's stock line well you got the
best one yeah I was gonna say yeah we
have he who remains and King the
Conqueror that both acknowledge that
there are good and bad kings but again
that's like talking to Satan and being
like Oh there's he's like I'm the good
Satan there is there's a bad thing there
is a good thing so it's like Santa you
switch they didn't do anything wrong
it's just a question God and I got him
thrown out he tore his wings Off You
cast them down into a lake of fire what
I was gonna say what I was gonna finish
saying is the fact that uh yeah it's
like couldn't we trust that there is
actually a good King but I think what we
can trust is there was a king that was
trying to stop the other kings from
coming because Kang uh he who remains
was doing it he took the that timeline
out of the way of the Kings for finding
it so it's like yeah I was trying to
stop this from happening I created the
entire TVA to stop this from happening
so I think there is such a thing as a
good King Plus at the beginning of the
Marvel uh the movie and they have the
Marvel letters and he who remains is in
it and I don't think there's been a lot
of times where a villain is in the
Marvel Legends maybe Ultron right yeah
speculated in his live breakdown that
that is because uh you know that that
alternate Kang that runs uh Kang with a
Q Industries and maybe owns Avengers
Tower at some point right and that's why
it was in the a right uh for Avengers uh
now Brandon we were talking right before
the show about Janet and her role with
this particular Kang right should she
have taken his deal so like Janet yeah
she helps them fix the ship and he's
like oh I'll check you back to your
Jelly Bean and she sees what's in his
mind and she's like no no I think she's
right because she knows that as soon as
she brings this Kang into the 616 he's
gonna destroy he's gonna conquer it and
this is a Kang if we believe he who
remains is not aware of the 616 can't
see it he's got his blinders on no Janet
doesn't know this but all she knows is
like if I allow this guy in he's gonna
destroy my world where my husband is
where my child is so she does the right
thing and like destroys the thing
destroys the device so he can't get out
again because he's the slowest Kang he's
too dumb to fix his shoes but I do see
your idea that like is it the council
that's bad and they sabotage his ship
because they don't like him and he's
doing the right thing I don't know but I
still think he's a bad guy because if he
comes to 616 he would destroy it do you
not think Janet was also just trying to
protect the other planets because I
think like I think that I think yes her
daughter was right the leading Factor
but I think she was also like I can't
have you just out there killing
everybody sure that that's also true she
saw the damage he did I know again The
Avengers spirit inside of her uh would
would have her do the right thing I mean
maybe I'm maybe I'm too
a little too sweet and innocent but uh
all the time I uh I took him at his word
in that I thought like they had the you
know kind of the quick establishing of
their relationship and friendship was
that he was saying like I am going to do
terrible things throughout the
Multiverse and I will leave your
Universe alone because you helped me and
you will never know the atrocities that
I am committing it's like basically like
push this button and kill a person on
the other side of the world like but get
a million dollars right like that's
basically what he offered yeah so and he
which you which is like I can't help you
you're gonna go do those things and he
immediately is like I will burn tomorrow
instead of being like no I was listen I
was bad in the past yeah yeah yes baby
it said he was like
yeah you're right but it to me it seemed
more like uh uh an insane an insanity
than it did like like an inability to
control that rather than it did a
deliberate like heel turn of like
you believed me I also think it is you
you can you can proffer is this like the
Green Goblin case right where the
knowledge of time and the knowledge of
how time operates which is what it kept
saying like you people don't understand
how time works you're thinking too
literally uh get it out literally uh
he's so burdened by this knowledge of
the way things actually are that he
can't help but do these things which by
us mere mortals is perceived of as wrong
but in his mind are the right thing to
do and he's like he's tired of dealing
with us peasants us ants I want to call
out a couple super chats uh the real
tree in the chat quantumania was fire
Emoji hell yeah
um uh Whiskey Bravo 85 TVA question
could miss minutes be the consciousness
of ravona rensslayer built by he who
remains only if he who remains is the
consciousness of cogsworth
then what happens and then he destroys
Miss minutes gears oh wow Christian Ford
has like a fun comment here about how
like the the size and the scope of the
battles in the MCU are kind of growing
bigger and so like inherently does that
mean we're probably going to get to
something bigger than End Game Boy both
we and Marvel would love that and thank
you Christian Ford that was your first
Super Chat according to our uh our Super
Chat analytics so I like that idea too
whereas like endgame you know with uh
infinity war was this big dramatic thing
affected the world end game resolved it
and brought things back to the way they
were with some problems that they're
still working out uh but I I still think
like the results of like Secret Wars by
the end of that will be like yeah
universes will still be destroyed yes
it's gonna make is it wouldn't make
battle world I think it will make battle
World pieces of different planets and
different timelines will be created into
this I think things will be collapsed
and people will never be able to go back
yeah the way things were interesting
yeah uh
that though all right trash bag in the
chat saying rip Modoc yeah I mean as two
members of the big head games I think we
mourn all our fallen soldiers anytime I
see a size I have a really big it
doesn't it may not look it but my head
is deep okay he's got a deep dive but
I'd like to go deep into it now let me
tell you this anytime I see a seven and
three quarters uh seven and a half fall
I I it's a little extra morning for me
that and I could be hogging up space he
was a he was 107. that guy could you
imagine if Kang one year was like we're
making fitted hats as Christmas gifts
for everybody down here uh Modoc what
are you about a 395 and 1
8.95. uh that that guy needs all the
beans to make a beanie oh my God that
I'm sorry we got to talk more about
Modoc because I think my experience
other people I know people thought he
was very goofy and silly and I couldn't
agree more but the people in my theater
loved Modoc and they were just
everything he did I wanted a good Modoc
profile where you could see the nose
really
it's hard to get a sense of scale I
don't the face looks so strange the
little the little like baby body when
they pull them out of the thing and then
put them into it was too much yeah
immediately Eric sent me a still of the
butt that's like he was like it was it
was but I I I will say if you're in a if
you're in a theater where people are
Modoc positive I think your opinion gets
skewed because I was prepared to be like
oh bro
and instead I was like oh brother big
head brother yeah
um yeah kind of Kevin uh coach kojanic I
hope I'm saying that right Kevin uh said
that like yeah he was kind of uh echoing
that like yeah there's goofy moments in
this movie obviously the Ant-Man
franchise is the goofiest probably up
there with Guardians in the most comedic
of all the MCU properties uh and it's
fitting because Comics often have really
goofy moments and I would like to see a
lot of these characters come back you
know all these like Quantum problem
characters and they might play a role
later down the line they keep aligning
with the ants who are super smart now
and technologically advanced go watch my
theory of what happens in the quantum
room because I go very deep deep into
that yeah um I go in on that but yeah
one of them has to be a superhero I
think I talked to you about this I was
like you're not going to explore a new
world a new realm and not one of them is
going to be like a superhero someone has
to come out of this world that's so big
it might be Fantastic Four uh I don't
know who knows yeah yeah uh Carter
Hawkins also in the chat said does Kang
become he who remains or maybe Victor
timely one of these uh Kang variants
that we're familiar with I'm sorry I
know I just I saw this movie hours ago
yeah it's precious it's fresh on me I
think that the king that was uh in the
uh uh final suck in gotta find I think
he's now in that that uh that uh what is
it land or uh the the children's box but
what like the probability probability
chamber I think that Kang is the one
being maybe Dr Doom possibly read riches
that brain can handle that type of thing
and I think he's in there creating
different outcomes basically doing a
like uh like uh a hack of a doctor
strange see like he's like brain hacking
Doctor Strange's million outcomes or
whatever he's just playing them all out
in that room like a chess board where he
can be like what if I do this what if I
do this what if I do this and I think
when he does get out he's going to be so
intellectually Superior and know like
that's gonna be part of his strength in
King Dynasty is he knows what all the
other people because he's killed all
these Avengers he has all is this whole
database of killing Avengers killing
Heroes now he can figure out a way to
kill them all again and I think he's
going to be unstoppable in that case
yeah I like that that's my theory yeah
uh and we've got a bunch of other uh
kind of Kang related uh oh actually TP
in the Super Chat gave the movie 4.9 out
of 5 which is very high TP uh but then
he adds I don't like how dumb how dumb
down King was so so you're a subscriber
to the slow cooking series I mean but
that's fair I mean he had one little
quandary but he or they had one little
quandary but they're still willing to
give the film a good score that's the
only thing that kept it from the five
out of five okay if you didn't like it
yeah this could all be revealed to be
part of King's master plan to make them
think he was stuck there but he wasn't
because he wanted them to come back for
whatever reason alone please I'm alone
because somehow modak was able to help
Ken figure out how to suck people in do
the initial suck in on people well I
think he's gonna get back now he was so
Advanced creating Modoc Modoc was so
Advanced and he was like oh I can do it
I just need to get a signal that's all I
need which is never gonna happen and
then one day I think our poor slow can
and you know even when push came to the
shop and it was time to launch he kept
being like okay launched the city and it
wouldn't launch he's like now I said
lunch there's tons of outtakes of him
pulling a push door yeah yeah yeah
he's got his thumb on the Button he's
like why aren't you idiots launching he
doesn't want to leave I don't want to go
on a tangent but just very quick uh
Brandon you're the slow King theory is
an actually an adaptation of your slow
Kong history yes could you just give
people the very Cliff Notes version of
slow calm you all saw Godzilla Godzilla
versus Kong there's a moment in the film
where Khan goes to the center of the
earth makes total sense uh and finds
that there was a whole civilization of
Kongs down there and these Kongs they
had written language they built weapons
and our boy Kong up on the surface was
just eating his own poop yeah
he was the dumbest of all he was the
dumbest Kong
stick it into a hot spring all the time
about this uh why is the other kings not
the the dumb down Kings in this King
because they tricked him they got him
well that's the thing that he was
outnumbered though he it was 1v3 or 1V a
million so we don't know how many people
actually uh mess with his engine and
threw him into a different time can
someone go tell Kang he just walked into
a closet again uh he keeps leaving
through the clock King your suit's on
backwards your cape's on your front wow
hey that's not how you sit in that chair
um wait that's actually maybe a good
theory and white kept sitting in that
chair all weird can't spying around on a
toilet they're like I think that's the
bathroom I'm Modoc now some of these
King quandries uh you know another
question we had like do you think
there's a chance that Janet you know
seeing all the atrocities of this King
do you think she actually could have
been seeing the atrocities of all the
kings when she touched that ship or was
you think that was just this particular
well when he freaked doubt that made me
think though our boys showed a pension
for uh destroying worlds and I think
they're each different so this is the
king the Conqueror suit we saw uh
slaying people versus a mortis or
Centurion or whatever well and and I'm
wondering too I was having this
conversation with you with Eric like all
these people in the quantum realm were
some of them there before Kang did Ken
pull these people down because my
interpretation of the whole thing was
that they were like refugees of Worlds
destroyed by Kang and he had pulled them
down there I don't know how he was
pulling them down from within the
quantum realm like as they were trying
to send signals out were they also
pulling in other people but then you
were saying like this what they're gonna
do and then you hear Hank Pym being like
Oh life evolved here I also yeah because
also it's like why would he pull people
from different planets that all speak
the same language they drink the Ooze
but did they each we didn't see them
every Wednesday everybody drank that guy
everyone you get those at a bar okay you
drink a couple shots
so do they milk that guy and then send
them out to all the bars in the quantum
room they're like I know they're like
Hang on we're out of ooze yeah I'm more
concerned about the Freedom Fighters
they're telling poor veb like no we need
your body juice yeah he's like you sure
you can't go to the store so I'm like
can't we make this uh
my bad we need it from The Source yes
Fab Jazz for us Jester juice for us no
hang on that we're talking about Quantum
run people then I want to get to my this
is uh something I really enjoyed about
this movie was the way the humanoid
Quantum realm residents were like
slightly uncanny valley the way they
talked like I thought William Harper
Jackson or William Jackson Harper's
character Bill Murray's character and a
couple of other characters they were
just a little bit off of like
I'm not to make you believe because my
thing all the all along was like those
guys were both going to be from from
Earth and then had been sucked down I
think no now I think that there are like
humanoids that were born in the quantum
realm just the way they talked the way
they were just like a little bit it was
like Cadence it was like especially
knowing those actors and how they
normally talked it gave me this like I
don't know if that was direction or
character Choice Google translated or
something yeah because she talked about
they were like Hank was like are you
human and Bill Murray was like damn near
close I could be he was like I thought
he was like oh like he made himself he
made himself but I also but even when he
but just their reactions to stuff like
when he was like ants those are ants do
we have ants like it was like almost
like Disney animatronic the way they
like he moved around I don't know I just
thought that was such an interesting way
to differentiate 616 earthlings and and
and Quantum realm humanoids I thought
that was is really well done and really
interesting would you say that somebody
that was not sucked into the quantum
realm but like was born there was like
it never sucked yeah I guess they've
been in ever suck they're a dry boy it
does it does remind me they're what's
known as a clogged pipe it does remind
me of both like on you know in Guardians
when we see like on xandar they're
aliens but they're so human in many ways
and even their customs and like the way
they interact it's maybe some slightly
different haircuts and outfits and
that's part of like some old Marvel
comic book or of the idea that the
celestial is like all life comes from an
original DNA and we're all very related
to aliens and that's why you can bang a
couple aliens and make a baby that all
life comes from the same genetic uh
building blocks and that would go all
the way down to the quantum realm yeah
and get so much there but the way they
do speak it does remind me of squid game
uh a movie made in Korea or show made in
Korea where most of the shows in Korean
but when they had the uh the you know
the foreign
English-speaking billionaires the way
they spoke was very strange so that's so
that's exactly what I was going to say
thank you for reminding me so Eric and I
actually met one of those guys last
weekend we met one of the actors one of
the VIPs yes his name was John D
Michael's very nice man he I'm not
trying to name that but he was just a
nice guy I want to give him the shout
out for this he played one of the VIPs
not the one who was naked he wants
everyone to know that very clearly he's
not he's not he was not he was not he
can't do nudes but uh but he's you know
he's an American actor that's been
working in Korea and he always plays
businessman or CAA like you know
officers or whatever and he goes we're
not playing Americans we're playing what
Koreans think Americans are like or
wherever else he works if he works in
Asia he's like it's a really it's a
crazy thing they get their scripts in
Korean and then they Google translate
them they don't ever even get what so
they have to figure out they have to
kind of guess who's like that's why all
that so he's like when when squid game
blew up I was like everyone's gonna love
this show and they're gonna the one
thing they're gonna hate is our parts
and we're gonna be in the line for it
never's gonna think that we're just
terrible so imagine if you're watching
this movie in the quantum room yeah
you'd be like that this is not an
honesty fiction of my home you'd be like
Quest would never talk like that uh he's
always saying weird offhanded racist
things uh Gerald mohabir sending a Super
Chat asking will any of these kangs be
the villain for the upcoming Fantastic
Four
right you know what I mean
so bad if they did it if they did it and
so you can do anything they killed Modoc
and we have the intelligence yeah and we
have the leader coming up we have a lot
of things about it could be in and they
kill them so they can do whatever
they'll be bad but uh or someone else I
was I was so obsessed with drama type
showing back up in Egypt because in the
comics he goes from being ramadet to
leaving to being someone else and then
going back to being raw mate because it
was so much fun and if that's what we
get into because feige was talking
slightly about a moon night season too
and I'm like oh go back in time go back
in time go see Rama Tut and it's going
to be Kang and it's gonna be beautiful
so that's where I want the I just I
that's why I want I would think that
this can't I think you know I think the
main Kang who got the second stuck in
not the initial second but the second
second into the power source he's gonna
be our long-term villain he's gonna be
our Kang Dynasty Secret Wars big villain
right I think the next time we see him
could be in Fantastic Four that would
ever worked like Fantastic Four is doing
uh whatever you know the science work
they're doing they're gonna find that
Canyon release him in like a weird way
which I think might be the most
interesting do you think he'll just come
out and destroy all the other kings
I think he's gonna be pissed now though
I don't know who he should be more mad
at is he more mad at the pims in the
last or is he mad at the pain
for them I also pitched that the first
people that the Kings will probably go
after are definitely the pins 100 of the
pims in the legs yeah after the pins and
legs it's gonna be like anyone that can
enter the quantum realm so it'd be Wanda
Agatha uh Doctor Strange Wong and maybe
possibly white Vision so they're gonna
line up
you guys think we're gonna get another
Modoc I think as I just said to the end
of that technology exists now and I and
ostensibly uh I could see I could see
Hank
or did Hank ever see Modoc yeah yeah
yeah yeah everyone had their moment of
being daring oh that's right I could see
Hank becoming obsessed with turning that
into a thing of for good and like maybe
like a Mobility tactic not maybe
necessarily making the giant heads and
accidentally making a modak like doing
the modak with the c like designed only
for computing right right but then it
ends up being uh only for killing again
like the Modoc Terrace I mean Darren
should be a character who keeps dying
and coming back I mean if they can if
they can make it Darren cross like we
think this should be the one that died
necessarily but it should I think now
that we're like
just opening the Multiverse we can get
which I again I'm so sorry I said this
in my videos uh we could get a darinless
cross or a just not Darren we can get
someone else or darrenless Modoc sorry
darrenless Modoc or we can get uh
someone that wasn't like in the first
movie maybe even a Louise like it could
be anyone else but Darren cross and it's
someone in a different timeline that was
a close friend that got sunk in I it
goes to uh a testament of what it truly
as he says or as he just called the
movie what a dick Darren cross was that
they didn't even try and bring his body
back they were like they were like leave
them in the rounds also
heard that it takes forever you know
what I just think it was a little bit uh
in poor taste to leave them there okay
let's talk about this post credit scene
guys we got uh we got I think I would
not be surprised if this was the second
post-credits scene was a look was a
scene cut from or out of lovely season
two oh yeah it's Loki and morbius back
together again I don't think morbius
still has his Memories Back Then I think
that this Loki has convinced this Mobius
he's got it
I think he Loki's trying to show him the
threat that Kang is and Mobius is like
this freaking guy is the threat the
Victor timely like he seems kind of like
a Whimsical smart man that's just trying
to do cool things and then Loki's like
no dude this is bad do you remember in
the earlier versions of uh the Marvel
movies where they literally would clip
out parts for them the post credits and
they just started doing it again with
this one Ragnarok they did it they did
it for civil war
they put a trailer up for Avengers at
the end of Iron Man 2 I believe yeah
yeah I love it well to your point right
we saw who is this hi I'm John hello
what happened here um foreign
okay guys now what do we think about the
TVA well well to your point with Victor
timely though is that he who remains
have they jumped back in time in a weird
way so oh my gosh oh yeah the time okay
go ahead they took well it's back in
time for sure well yeah but I mean is he
who remains or is he someone from a
different time because I mean a mortis
literally was three different characters
before he was a mortise so is Victor
timely always been Victor timely or was
he he who remains that escape to become
Victor Tyler I gotta think Loki season
two is gonna show us the origins oh it
has to be he remains right better and
and to your point earlier uh about like
Loki trying to be like this is what
happened we do get that we got that shot
from like one of those Disney plus
promos of Loki basically like stabbing
that wall with the pruning thing and I
think one of the heads of the
timekeepers was on the ground well it
was like a stat it was like a mosaic of
the original Three timekeepers I think
that scene is him basically being like
it's all [__] yeah
so we think he might be he who recains
exactly no I think Victor timely is uh
Victor timely but this is also me basing
it off of him in the comics that I like
I don't the MCU could change it and make
him actually connected to he he remains
but uh I like that sorry the monitor
keeps switching to Tommy uh I like the
idea of Victor timely coming from uh
timely Wisconsin and creating the
original
um uh uh uh uh Human Torch and just
teaching his entire staff the advance of
Robotics and making the worst kind of
villain do we think that timely which I
think in the comics becomes chronopolis
and goes into the quantum room I think
he takes the whole town into the quantum
realm with him to escape is that going
to be our next entry into the quantum
realm is is Victor timely gonna oh could
we be in the quantum realm in in Loki
season two is Michael yeah he makes like
a little portal to chronopolis through
timely Wisconsin uh that'd be sick as
hell well I mean [__] Cassie can open
portals to the quantum Realm well well
no she needs to have them have the power
source but Kang has that assuming right
many kings have time chairs there was
the time chair with the power source uh
Janet hooks it up yep and it opens up
the portal she moves some circles she's
got some very janity stuff it gets you
smarter than slow Kang so she's able to
program it to do this thing very quickly
and then all Cassie did was like open it
back up again it still had the power
source in the quantum realm which is now
gone but it's also like what's the
equivalent to the power source in my
video I compared America Chavez's powers
to the quantum energy ball because they
do have the same powers and same with
ghosts ghost is literally a ball of the
same Quantum energy so if ghost like
allegedly just did her powers on this
device she can open the portal hey I
like that because now they have gifts
they have ants on the inside right they
have a society of hands oh yeah they
could design them okay keep working on
the technology
now so here's my here's my I'm gonna
give you guys a lightning room because
then we're gonna do some questions from
the chat after that to close out this
bad [__] uh you guys got one chance to
go into the quantum realm to bring
someone out for for your for your help
for your usage who are you pulling out
of the realm who you [__] out of the
room you pluck out of the realm yeah we
know the second but for the final pull
out who are you taking out no shot him
taking anyone but the guy the the gloopy
guy with no holes you're taking bab I'm
taking the fat ball I'm taking one of
the hands I'm giving you I'm gonna suck
that dude bone drop whoa
oh
talk to God
our God is an awesome God and he's King
from the heavens
you gotta shoot your shot when you come
on this show I would take an amp but I'm
so afraid of an Ambien shot that I can't
get another pant so I'd probably I'd
probably take genuinely which yeah I
guess I just have her teach me to fight
gentura yeah
she she was so mean I'll take class my
mind reading friends I don't want him
reading my mind all the time can you die
no no
questions just look at me
I forget his name yeah all right Peter
they reminded me the only victim yeah I
told Ashley and Evan this they remind me
so much of Korg and meek oh yeah I just
I do want to throw out one thing to Kang
again slow Kang when you're designing
your soldiers and they're moving someone
they're moving someone uh they're moving
a prisoner by walking on both sides of
them multiple times in this film we saw
people get out of that scenario by
punching one and then punching the
others you got to train them so watch
out when they're walking someone down a
hallway watch out yeah because they'll
make a move and they'll get away if
you're not careful they were the
easiestly tricked uh henchmen I've seen
in a while I also think uh I maybe okay
my pick is I'm taking one of those
sentient buildings oh that's a good one
that can turn into they can turn into
ships and shoot lasers out of there and
also if the solicitor comes up towards
the house they will shoot it yeah that's
a good one I would say like no it's okay
no it's okay all right let's get into
some uh clean that giant house through
the portal let's see here okay uh we got
Gerald mahabir said that's why we did
this one already okay that's right sorry
Gerald uh oh our friend flight ninja 808
could TVA be in the quantum realm or
maybe limbo this is an interesting
question because we we have this
discussion a lot and even in this movie
they kind of throw out Realms Dimensions
universes uh and even the way Janet
describes the quantum realm as like it
being way more and she says something
like subatomica and stuff like that
other things that exist in Marvel Comics
I I'm gonna cut you off real fast we're
gonna go along today I might try to grab
Eric later I'm not totally sure before
we answer more of your questions we do
have to think
uh we did our Movie Club yesterday we
had a bunch of fun
um and one of the ways that we did that
was we accessed Netflix in another
country
um so that we could watch something like
because it wasn't on Netflix
um so if you haven't checked out nordvpn
yet
um check out the link in this video's
description it's on screen now it's
great it's really helpful and I gotta
say I love using nordvpn not only for
access to like movie that are in
streaming in the US or you can access
like free to play games that aren't
available in the US or like gaming
websites like that you can also and ask
us how we get footage at new rockstars
for some of our videos uh I'm not going
to get into the details of that I use
nordvpn to uh to check it out those
things but also when you're just like
surfing the internet you can just set
yourself to an you can change your
location just to protect yourself from
your own ISP who will like monitor your
activity and put ads on stuff uh nordvpn
will also help block like malware and
suspicious sites like that it does a lot
more than just you know helping you
watch movies in other countries but that
is a great thing you can do with it and
I want to apologize I did say that
Zombieland was available on thrust for
for a low low price it turns out that
was that was salambi land uh which is
about salami that gets zombified uh it's
a disturbing movie no one should ever
watch it nordvpn also I believe will
protect you from
uh no one can protect you well how do I
get nordvpn John hey grab your exclusive
North VPN deal by going to
nordvpn.combreak room we said it before
Okay click the link in this video's
description
um they're gonna give you a big big old
fat discount okay
um and a bonus
gift what is the bonus gift it's not
gonna be every day they're gonna send
you a photo of Murdoch's a little tushy
not that gift please
um risk-free because they have a 30-day
money-back guarantee we've kind of been
saying we're going to be doing these
nerd VPN deals
um uh Movie Club things every month so
if you get it now you'll have it for the
next time we do another weekend we wish
we could do it every week I love it I
love a movie club well
um you'd have to ask Brandon to join his
brand name won't talk to me no I refer
not speaking I refuse
um sorry that was a wild that was a good
that was a good that was fun you did a
great job borrow it's 50 asking us a
nice question how did Loki get in 1800s
King I think he convinced Mobius right
yeah well this kind of goes back to that
question to the TV area
yeah what the TVA is is it in a limbo I
mean when it was described on the show
here's here's my thing with the TVA okay
people keep talking about the TVA as
they saw in Loki as like a Bible of like
how the TVA works it's not the TVA was
all a lie it only exists that's a good
point I I only it doesn't exist against
all multiverses it is attached to the
616. it was a stealth cloaking device
you used to keep the 616 out of the
purview of all the other kings we saw in
the post-credit sequence right that that
came all the Council of Kings they look
out the window they're like
and you could see all the time streams
you could see them colliding when we
were with he who remains at the Citadel
at the end of time or whatever it was
called it was a circle he was inside the
circle of the 1616 and that's where the
TVA lives it is attached to that one
thing and I think it's important to note
within the 616 there are still multiple
times multiple timelines yeah right so
even though it is part of one universal
are still multiple timelines
that are considered to be sacred right
and they'll prune them accordingly and
we know they can they can ride up and
down these timelines to a point in time
that they want to go I have a question
for you guys this is just a personal
opinion when Kang is going ham outside
his King Fortress and he's using the
blue energy too is is that the same
technology or maybe a more advanced
technology than the prune sticks
well yeah so his power comes from his
suit I mean he's jacked right he's a big
dude but the whole thing was he needed
the ship to get the suits I'm talking
about the blue laser specifically though
were those pruners I don't think they
were pruners I think they were like
you're dead you're just vaporized you're
dead you don't think they all went to
the Land of Confusion you know what's
interesting so he does uh Janet at one
point mentions the void as part of the
quantum realm now I I think that the
void that she's referencing is different
from the voice right or something like
that there's layers and one of them is
called the void and I think the void is
referencing to that sort of like that
like black void that we see in the first
on the first man movie right and not
like the void from uh from Loki but it
was when she said that my ears perked up
and I was like oh are we gonna get to
see Elias again at least she didn't say
shadow realm yeah tired of everything
being named The Shadow realm yeah why
can't it be the sunny round uh Kalia
Allen says what's Cassie's superhero
name we didn't get one Eric Boston his
predictions was right he was sort of
like they don't really do that they did
it
bit they didn't miss Marvel but it was
like a cute thing for her dad to give
her at the end really do they never call
Janet or hope wasp I think hope uh hope
and
um Scott are taking on the monikers from
hey
you know like back in the 70s maybe it
was less uh it was more invoked like
this is like wrestling a lot of
wrestlers keep their real name now they
don't take on fake names anymore but the
guy to name myself but this is the same
problem we have with problem issue with
like Elena beloved is this the new
generation right it's Elena it's uh uh
okay Bishop it's it's Cassie Lang it's
like give them give them fun superheroes
you can call me Tommy tiny sack bechtold
and I'll be at WrestleMania knocking
around all the bad guys Sam walked by
with the saddest scared face on her Sam
always looks sad when she says I did
they will probably be a deleted scene
scene where we see two members of the
quantum realm people the Freedom
Fighters being like wow look at her
stature and then the other one's like
this is a real sticker and they'll be
like it's statue it's Stinger I'm sure
we'll get that example and then they rip
each other yeah
I'm sure we didn't see more of those uh
duplicating spider things yeah oh that's
a good question those I'm when I was
sitting in the theater I was like I
wonder if Kang sent those and then say
like something like Janice like win
favor over I don't think that was like
but yeah for a little while I was like
did Kang do that on purpose so that he
could save Janna I know I think they
were ended up I think they're probably
Quantum realm creatures but
um I thought that for a minute Rosario L
sent in a Super Chat saying uh so does
everyone uh have an unlimited supply of
pin particles in there in their suit
because I felt like they used so much
and they were never worried about
running out you gotta think at the end
of end game uh it was hard for them to
get pimp articles they were like hey you
gotta get to work yeah yeah I'm trying
to have little shrunk down pin particles
so they can make bait like there's like
little ones now that I have the van the
Pim van dime Foundation I'm sure they
have an amount of that's astronomical
well and this is like as soon as Tony
was able to interact with wakanda he
suddenly had a nanotech Iron Man suit
it's like now that and now they have
nanotech Ant-Man and wasp suits that are
so smart that it put your tasseled hair
into the helmet nice without cutting it
off yeah yeah I imagine they must have
like a more robust system for making
pimp Boston a lot of blue screen videos
that we don't usually Blue Screen Video
term I can't believe you said that
publicly um
a lot of videos who's talked about
um
how like Tony will build in fixes the
problems that he has in the previous uh
movies so yeah this feels like that
where they were like okay we need a we
need a basically an infinite Supply can
they pee in those suits I mean they have
enough pen particles now that like
Hawkeye's getting arrows so it's like
yeah is that there's not a short supply
on yeah on PPS anymore coulson's got pin
bullets we don't know the whole goon
squad's getting pin parted yeah yeah
they're giving they're giving everyone a
payment uh one of our great moderators
crispy said uh crispy Chrissy says
imagine what would happen if Wanda and
Kang teamed up I think we'd all be
[__] if it uh reality doesn't implode
first I do like wait yeah or secret war
or anything possible I I think Wanda is
hiding in the quantum realm I think
that's I think she's down I think that's
where she went when she turned red I
agreed that she's probably alive but I
think a great replacement for Wanda is
just using Agatha now and Agatha is
still under her little brain spell so we
don't know if she's gonna be good or bad
when she gets out of it and that I think
is something that can be easily
are you saying that you think Agatha is
being puppeted by Wanda to a degree well
yeah I think the power is still on her
because in coming to chaos didn't we see
it like her mall scene where she's still
dressed like she looked she was like
sort of in black and white and then we
saw her out of her her real witch attire
and I assume
shekinson was not evil she wasn't wrong
at all I gotta help everybody thumbnail
for this video is was King a good guy I
say yes was that is that a good guy yeah
kind of what's your argument for Kang
being a good guy
I I think I mean like Tommy you're right
maybe all Kang's excuses is gonna be
like well the other things are worse but
he was TR he it seemed like he wasn't
lying to Janet it seemed like he was
really like let's go let's get out of
here I'm bringing you to your family he
told Jenny he wasn't going to destroy
her Universe
um maybe but like there's other
universes to destroy I really do think
tank was like Hey you saved my life I
owe you one I'm not gonna [__] with you
when you're dead because that's how time
works maybe I'll destroy the six I just
had a vision okay a white vision
wait not that kind
of uh Walter White Vision uh I'm gonna
start cooking no uh what if the end of
Kang Dynasty is Wanda and Agatha
trapping a bunch of Kings in their own
like nightmares and they all are
repeating over and over again you don't
want to kill me the other ones are way
worse than you just hear and it just
stacks on stacks on Stacks so you have
like a thousand kangs being like
repeated it's like that news thing when
Sinclair broadcasting made all the
anchors say like yes Liberty has never
been more at risk and it was like a
thousand people saying it's all the
kings being like if you kill me way
worse ones will come and it's like times
a thousand uh I just could see that
happening I have a question for you guys
the world that Scott comes back to at
the end is it the same 616 oh I think
that's a separate break room topic or a
separate solo video topic for the time
Dasha brought this up and I think oh my
God I would have loved this ending that
they are stuck in the quantum realm but
when they get out Cassie's uh aged and
she's old and everything has changed
it was like Jeff do this do this Jeff
just please do this uh but what if he
comes back and what if she he comes back
and she was you know like eight again
yeah and he's like I got what I wanted
but it seems so [__] wrong man I lost
a different version of my daughter I
think he's not back and I think when
that portal closed at the end and
reopened it was not the same place
because because when Loki comes when he
who remains died and Loki goes back to
the TVA everything has changed so I'm
very like uh Back to Future Part Two
scenario I think the same thing has
happened here and the fact that we can
hear Scots in our thoughts it's very
bizarre and all the green and purple all
at the beginning he's doing a reading
and at the end unless he wrote a really
[__] up sequel to his book yeah it's
stream of Consciousness
also I did love the line read poor Hank
didn't get enough Line rides in this
movie but nailed every one of them yeah
but he said I read every gun yes you
know what pissed me off I was like I
don't know if it was an insult or a
celebration I know people have
complaints about this movie my only
complaint is that the line reading of I
just saved eight bucks was so much
better in the trailer than it was in the
movie it was so good in the trailer
in the trailer hey Kyle Avery says why
was this King the most feared but lost
to Giant Scott uh no moves wasted was a
quote by Major scenes like quite a few
moves were wasted unfortunately I hear
that complaint I know people are like
he's the dumbest guy well I know
people are commonly frustrated that new
rockstars like comes in and like has
theories for why things maybe didn't
work for people in movies but there is a
possibility that a I think this is true
this King did not die B if Kings can see
all versions of the future and time
works differently for them it's very
possible that like going into this sort
of uh probability storm was you know
something that this Kang was interested
in or whatever you could say like why
didn't they do it earlier I don't know
the answer that but like you could say
it's possible that this is the outcome
that he wanted so Kyle's point and play
double advocate for Kyle uh I was also
bullied I was like it
I wanted there to be consequences and I
wanted to be higher stakes and the
stakes were very high but it was more so
like I was like I don't need the speech
of you killing every avenger and every
Thor if you can't beat hope and Hank all
right wow in their own movie but he's
like those are so hard he's looking
Beyond them right he's like he talks
down to them by saying like you you talk
to ants like what is this better than
you a school for ants I don't have the I
don't even like wasting time about
dealing with you and he does he he
wastes moves by being like no I'm Gonna
Get Physical I'm gonna physically fight
them and waste time like zapping people
because he is so easily triggered
because he's the dumbest Kang he's so
easily triggered by people like
questioning him that he goes into fits
of Rage yeah like he's an idiot but also
it's it's worth reminding people and and
maybe you didn't want this to happen but
it is what happened in the movie this is
a significantly de-powered King he is
without his his suit he is trapped he he
and he's always had a suit he's without
his uh time chair his suit does start to
malfunction there at the end it gets
kind of [__] up
um it's damaged he doesn't have any way
to like repair that it's he's in the
middle he's got his guns out so I I I
mean you I I understand my complaints
that like this King was taken down by an
army of ants uh uh I see it a hundred
percent he is significantly depowered
and there's people online saying things
like you know why should I be fearful of
Kang when you know this Kang was so
easily defeated that's Ant-Man the
movie's called Ant-Man wow but was he
supposed to be defeated by water lilies
I think it's okay of people have
different like no a thousand percent
right I just want to remind people this
is not the Kang that we're gonna get in
future movies they're gonna they're
gonna power Kanga to that point I think
that they should have pulled that across
more yeah because definitely for me I
was even like I don't think this is a
deep powered King but I get what you're
saying look at me this movie is called
Ant-Man the popcorn bucket is an Ant-Man
helmet not a Spider-Man helmet not a
Thor helmet not another helmet it's an
Ant-Man helmet Loki or can you be
defeated by ants because it's called
Ant-Man it's not that hard guys it's
titling uh it's also okay but it was um
I was so close so close to getting one
Theory right on Cassie dying and when he
was choking her I said killer I said
killer I was like just kill her bring
her back just kill her and bring her
back and I I was like I was like I might
win
you had a lot of close theories Brandon
Brandon was on board that like either
Hank or and it would turn and work with
Kang turns out Scott kind of did that
yeah Brandon said uh you said Hank and
Jana getting stuck or the other one's
getting stuck it closed I was like
Brandon's right yeah we're gonna go have
a trouble with Lord krylar
um hey next week on the break room we're
going to be talking a lot more about
quantumania we're gonna probably revisit
our predictions and kind of say who was
right about things who was wrong about
things but thank you so much for joining
us today on the break room
um hey if you didn't know this which I
can't believe you wouldn't know this we
launched a new channel today all right
Channel today there are four new videos
on a different Channel than new
Rockstars it's called The Deep dive
thank you it's called The Deep dive um
we've got a an amazing deep dive into
Wanda Vision I'm talking about like all
of her grief and like where why that's
like such an important through line of
that story from that show it was a
little bit of grief uh it was it wasn't
for sure
um well it is great and amazing I love
persevering an amazing Deep dive on Loki
which is even more significant now that
we we came out of quantumania and I
think Eric was like I'm so glad that I
wrote that he wrote that video like two
or three weeks before we saw quantumania
um and then uh if you don't have a ton
of time today there's a great 16 minute
piece on how trailers are deceptive
um Eric did a ton of research it's like
backed by years of us doing trailer
analysis on this channel
um plus some like secret stuff that we
can't talk about because it's so secret
um I am ready to announce though there
is a four hour video of Eric helping me
find my belly button no that one's
unlisted so ask Tommy for the link on
Twitter that one's on thrust which we
are offering a sale you use code thrust
69420 for 89 off for the next 20 years
89. 89 I want 20 less than that
um and then Eric this morning did a a
live breakdown of uh Ant-Man and the
lost quants Mania and kind of like did a
pullback of the curtain of how we break
down movies on this channel super cool
it was awesome check that out um but in
addition to that on the new Rockstar's
Channel our Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
media breakdown is now out you can watch
maybe right now it's on the channel uh
so close this tab go watch that video uh
we'll see you guys on Sunday for Our
Last of Us episode six
session yes it's okay
to go to Deep dive and then go to mine
no Jessica on uh tomorrow tomorrow
Jessica has an amazing theory about the
quantum realm in particular do you want
to give a little preview uh I just
talked about what the quantum I'm sorry
is gonna look like in the MCU during
phase five and six listen to me camera
four please
we got a lot of content coming out okay
we got two different channels we got
great videos every video is worth your
time I want you to remember something
very important your family will never
die
you don't need to spend time with them
this weekend watch the videos play the
videos your family will be fine okay you
can see them you go apple picking with
them next weekend watch the con you must
watch the content how much butter was in
that box must watch the content I do
think we put out 11 videos in the last
you can do it if you get all eleven I
want you to hashtag me Tommy b11 video
meltdown and I will respond to you with
a profanity lace tirade yeah this is the
most content we've ever put out into a
two-day period in my history in the rock
stars which is a long time I've been
here for a while uh thank you guys so
much we'll be back on Sunday and then a
regular live break room on Tuesday of
next week sorry that the schedule is a
little bit just check in check in every
day
we'll see you later
[Music]